[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi io sono fa vince
benvenuti a questo nuovo gameplay questo
il nuovo horror che mi piace fare tanto
alla fine poi mi fa tutti cagliari tutti
ragazzi e bene devo solo video sono fa
vige oggi siamo sul resto è che il gioco
con più ritmo della storia ma quasi
quasi io provo a forlì in spagnolo a
cazzo propria volta nella storia in
gioco in spagnolo che non parte perfetto
a in inglese parte allora niente proprio
un cazzo è una demo ragazzi quindi non
so quanto può non dimenticarti di
utilizzare la torcia 13 3 2015 no col
cazzo è un po più avanti sia così
c'è una statua mio dio ragazzi la voglio
nel mio giardino è troppo bella
soprattutto di notte
non esco di casa manco se mi sparano
proprio perché bei posti re che madonna
manco outlast ma cos'è sta roba mi fa
fare tutta la panoramica prima di fare
no che figo
minchia un horror fatto decentemente va
sei serio ma un avo per una volta nella
vita
non faccio un cazzo io sono così ci sono
tranquillo sapevo molto comodo e
semplice sto gioco non chi cazzo era
quello che avete visto anche voi
e c'è uno morto adesso dovrei essere io
il problema è che c'è un tizio di in una
porta che non andrò a vedere mai nella
vita cioè i mal di pancia fratello
mangiato fagioli sei a posto
domanda doma ascolta accusa le gambe non
si usa il legame vabbè dai si impara con
tutorial bravo vai così ma in forza su
tifiamo per lui un bell'applauso così
almeno si alza su si carica basic
commons non è che io io so come giocare
anche se non ho mai giocati vitali e la
roba tipo a è in terza persona ma cazzo
ho mai giocato un horror in terza
persona sul mio canale bellissimo bravo
ho capito perché i mal di pancia non ci
vuole molto
[Musica]
e normale che premendo un tasto si fa la
trottola sto tizio faccio la torcia
ragazzi il mio cuore la torcia io il
lumino col mio cuore bellissimo delle
vado a c'è un kit medico prima cosa non
sappiamo come cazzo si è finiti qui ma
il kit medico mi sembra di giocare daino
crisis cazzo questo era il mio telefono
falso allarme ma hanno rifatto tipo quei
giochi della playstation 1 che più o
meno simili si è sicuri come i bagnini
di baywatch
[Musica]
ce la facciamo adesso spinge che bello
l'uomo che spinge gli armadi non hai a
rotelle però slitta non si sa perché i
ragazzi a parte 6 cagato e come ci siamo
finiti laden qualcuno c'ha la
spiegazione perché non c'è un tizio qui
c'è un tizio che ho visto anche prima
mentre c'era la panoramica kiss kiss
identificati stronzo io ma vicino coi
miei movimenti molto sexy
senti zio io non so chi tu sia chi sto
puntando una torcia in faccia a vomita
adesso una porta rinforzato tutta nera
un tuono sembra che si può sapere
tramite un dispositivo elettronico ma io
non voglio aprire un cazzo amico mio non
è capito se il tizio rimani pure lì che
io vado via non ho capito che cosa dura
ma ce ne sono tanti ma che bello che sei
è vero ma che belli ragazzi ma sono miei
amici questi allora ma sono tutti qua
porca di quella [ __ ] cos'è cos'è era ok
chi cazzo è quello la lega sa bene
allora e io io me ne tornerei molto
tranquillamente nella mia stanzina
ragazzi io ve lo dico sta diventando
inquietante ma chi minchia è quello
sullo sfondo di preciso il cazzo ecco è
sparito perfetto qualcuno ames trovato
tranquillamente sul materasso ragazzi
che cosa sta succendo spiegate come ci
sono film ascolta uomo io non so se
amici 9 che aspettano un attimo io non
so non so c'è un orsacchiotto io ascolto
devo prendere atto è sparito a caso va
bene c'è un orsacchiotto però è una
cuccia per che sentite e non sto capendo
il senso di sta roba offshore ma mi
prendi per il culo io entro e non c'è
esco e c'è ma senti se ti nascondi da me
non ti lamentare se poi non ti vengo a
salvare se poi non amici e se sei al
sociale so cazzi tuoi file la minchia
che ti pare io me ne vada tanto non mi
interessava a conoscerti credimi ho
degli amici migliori ditte bastardo
altra gente nelle porte va beh
porca put non ho detto niente contro le
porte che cosa ti incazzi una delle leve
non equa sembra che il sistema sia
bloccata devo trovare una leva a
prefetto dato bellissimo come sale sulla
lattina sopra senza che si schiacci è
meraviglioso sono questi rumori orribili
mi odio fatemi uscire cos'è sta zona
indecente c'è una roba a te è quella la
leva è lì a terra spiegatemi perché
buongiorno quella siringa se la mette
nel culo mi fa un favore grazie no
ascolta ascolta mi ascolti mi ascolti
eva [ __ ] questo morgan freeman
questo dovrebbe essere ragazzi sta cosa
è successo mi ha preso uno a caso il
collo ma cosa mi sono risvegliato mi ha
fatto una puntura cazzo deve lopez by ma
è partito adesso cosa sta succedendo
spiegate voglio delle spiegazioni
logiche cos'è la fai svegliarti zio devo
c'è una gnocca
c'è un anno accademie michiara forte
quella droga
sto bene ragazzi c'è lo stesso telefono
come possibile ma sii serio questo
inquieta parecchio 2 so cos'è ahi ahi
diventati in prima persona ad es come ma
era partito in terza persona è diventato
in prima persona a caso come è successo
e cos'è un bambino che tenero ascolta
zia e chi tu sei molto gnocca io devo
andare però aspettami perché torno colpe
né duro preset winter ex nave dai
usciamo di qualche meglio lo hanno
portato ma solo è un sogno forse a cazzo
capito perfetto aperte parali gar
meno male che ho scelto inglese come
lingua queste sei sceglievo arabo che
cazzo usciva cioè io sento st musica da
[ __ ] che arriva dal piano di
sotto e lega non ho capito perché al
televisore forse ma quanto e castle in
one eye to uomo chi si addormenta massei
mia figlia sei mia moglie chi cazzo se
lei sia addormentata ok spenga la
televisione rapporto subito ma
[ __ ] televisore cos'è successo
karen karen ho bisogno del mio telefono
non posso dire niente ragazzi ragazzi
col cazzo che io sto qua come faccia a
la torcia c'è la torcia del del telefono
ma come cazzo andata ma chi era quella
la mia figlia mia amante chi cazzo mi
sembra giocare a paranormal aiuto
ragazzi aiuto a cazzo aiuto ma display
sapri la differenza fra dispersa preti
la nutella maggio dov'è la nutella dove
cazzo devo andare lì capii che non ha
pagato le bollette si stranzi ragazzi
cosa chi cosa
guarda che se violenti mia moglie ti
denuncio a bell'uomo dove credi di
andata non posso più andare su e giù si
lega ma non vorrei seguirlo in realtà io
stavo bene dove stavo ascoltati o ti
faccio fare anche il bucato se te ne
stai buono da dove cazzo arriva a tua
madre lo sapete
buongiorno dovete usare la lavatrice ora
che ce n'è per tutti ecco perfetto prima
loro prega ragazzi è questo tu sei molto
bello ascoltata raga io io dovevo uscire
di qui devo andare no no no no no allora
va bene
vi do una mano a fare il bucato però
state calmi cazzo usciamo di qui non hai
la testa ma sei più bello degli altri gr
è stato un piacere e fate come se fosse
a casa vostra anche tu che sei nano io
me ne vado dalle balle cosa ma hanno
chiuso bastardi eve che si vogliono
usare tutta la lavatrice sinistra anzi
mi chiami si sprecano tutta l'energia
c'è una donna senza gambe al lavello
perché scolti bella signora se deve
usare la lavatrice è debole non deve
usare la lavatrice secondo me non sia
senti un attimo non è che possiamo cosa
fai no no che è costato un casioni sull
no me lo ripaghi tutto in natura è
capito lurida [ __ ] paranormal mele
[Musica]
ragazzi cosa sta succedendo o mio dio
possiamo uscire di qua grazie chi oserà
però tua sorella tesoro amo amore ma se
vuoi dare il bianco alle pare ne
parliamo
si parla tra mari tema richiamiamo un
imbianchino chiamiamo un imbianchino e
ci facciamo il mio caro
ok lo sapevo [ __ ] [ __ ] cos'è questo è
il cane che hai dato da mangiare al cane
troppo tesoro ancora tu morgan freeman
matt e via don mi to back cos'è successo
io cosa ho fatto a te ma sei tu rimetti
lato una siringa che cazzo vuoi questi
credono di aver ragione pure ma queste
sti stronzi non ha fottutamente avuto
senso sta cosa ma va bene sonoma di
nuovo ma basta vi prego basta allora
ascolta zio mi spieghi o morgan freeman
è un mago a cui dicevo lo stronzo di
prima è che un coltello o che cazzo e
qui può eccolo qui minchia meno male
posso fare il culo la gente adesso
meluso racconta è la co della bravo zio
bravo sì però i non voglio ma non so che
cosa ha fatto questo verso ma io non
esco di qua silver amulet cosa cazzo me
ne faccio quale dei due era un sogno
quale è un sogno questo qui o quello di
prima e la meglio col di prima a me non
c'era la mia donna cos'è di che fasti
versi non aprite questa porta e un altro
film c'è una pista si scherzava apriamo
fra un cazzo non apre un cazzo cos'è
porta numero uno si no ma tanto non la
proviene sbatti cogianco accadeva la pro
recco è affatto una stanza so dove si
trova la leva l'ho vista prima prima che
morgan freeman mio ammazzasse vado a
prenderlo ok piano equa la leva non cede
sul nero che mi fa uno scherzo vero
ditemelo
minchia meno male in compenso c'è lui
che sembra quello dell'attacco di
giganti conta zio
con tutto il rispetto che ho per la tua
bellissima sek saggi ne devo
accoltellare la faccia
ecco ecco che cosa fa oh mio dio ha
tirato fuori un qualcosa di più di un
coltello dalla dall'anca perché non ha
le tasche poverino realtà possiamo
giocare la carta forbice sasso per
vedere chi vince non è meglio ti prego
eccolo è morto ho vinto io come ho fatto
a vinci dice che che tac e maestria nel
combattere ragazzi bellissimo
comunque ho trovato la leva quindi
usiamo almeno questa perfetto allora
apro la porta no devo aprire la porta
numero uno non le apro tutto su tre non
sapevo senti zio allora che braccia
belle che c'hai
ma magari se ne aprivo soltanto uno era
meglio [ __ ] [ __ ] chiudi ho già perso
non c'entro prima veloce sì l'ho preso
l'ho presa come come faccio a usare la
famiglia cazzo che goduria dove sei
bastardo vieni nostra mamma che mira del
cazzo che c'è un fermo un attimo fermo
fermo fra non abbassarti alzati veloce
no non mi toccare ti denuncio vieni qua
la brava vieni qua però perché se non
riesco a prenderlo ma l'ho preso luci
rito che è bella anche a te ti consiglio
la manicure dall'estetista zio non è che
ci hai delle mani bellissima allora
forse possa aprire le tutte le portate
sono invincibili
anzi dov'è andato quello stronzo di
prima
non ho idea di dove sia ma fa il verso
delle mucche e lo fa bene ecco lo vieni
qui vieni qua fuori noi no no no
proietti poiché si caricasse cazzo di
ecco no no no no no però magari mentre
non ti segue grazie duri doppi di
crepare eccolo lì è morto anche la cosa
devo fare io ragazzi devo libera tutti
la potenza di 1000 uomini attenzione
signori incredibile hulk 2.0 bravissimo
non so come fa
sì l'ho fatta ho centrato il buco chi
cazzo è quello ragazzi perché c'è uno
nudo che si toglie le armi dal petto
crepa identificati i denti e non crepa
però diventato fumo tutto fumo e niente
arrosto non fa ridere mi dovevo tirare
una colonna in testa ho ucciso uno nudo
mi sono sentito onnipotente passo una
scritta la giustizia dovrebbe essere
cieca ma comunque il suo prezzo 36 euro
non so che cosa è successo ma c'è un
altro nudo ma basta uomini nudi ragazzi
uomini nudi rigirano a cazzo cioè non ha
senso la senti zio con le tue belle
chiappe no o finiti proietta troyer che
definire i proiettili nel momento giusto
non mi toccare il magone della polizia
proprio stronzo club fumo eva fans fumo
e niente vi è riuscito accoltellarmi
senza sparire è che palle non c'e verso
luce quando non c'è madonna o raga non
ci credono e morto ho finito pure i
colpi come ha fatto ma fatemi usare il
coltello che cassano non ci posso
credere
senti ziativa di crepare o devi stare in
piedi piuttosto ecco bravo di moriremo
donna guarda sul ginocchio proprio che
merda di ginocchio che ci ascolta non
muore in culo tutto mondo cosa ho
colpito l'area ha ucciso l'aria ragazzi
ho paura che sia ancora vivo perchè non
è diventato fumo intanto ti ammazzo al
piede non ho capito cosa è successo ma
va bene sembra che qualcosa possa
entrare qua dentro trovato un amuleto ha
capito celo celo celo celo ma che roba
vecchia roba bakker
la maglia che è roba caso ha vinto un
calcio in faccia
no niente si è spenta la fontana e vi
chiamo lo spreco dell'acqua questo vinto
mio dio e la camera adesso diretti cazzo
tubi continua a caso ma come ma cosa è
successo
no vabbè ma non può finire così il cazzo
apertura chiamerà i segreti ragazzi per
camera dei segreti è stata aperta ci
abbiamo tutti nel culo e stato bello
molto istruttivo
spero che video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
spero di essere riuscito ad catapultarvi
in un atmosfera horror diversa dal
solito che non ho capito manco io sento
sei video è piaciuto lasciato momento mi
piace anche a far geni facebook e come
nei video trovate una vestizione se non
sono vestiti siete vicini vediamo lo
possiamo video sai cassino che vuol dire
bella ragazzi in sap endesa da ragazzi